[Musique]
plus de 120 représentants associatifs
communal économique ou encore public et
une cinquantaine en distance yale se
sont réunis à l'initiative de la caisse
d'allocations familiales
un colloque pour réfléchir
collectivement à l'avenir celui du
schéma départemental des services aux
familles maisons d'assistants maternels
le premier schéma sur 2014 2017 avec
comme axes la petite enfance et la
parentalité
il permet aujourd'hui de faire un bilan
des actions qui a un gros travail qui a
été fait pour établir un diagnostic pour
démarrer un certain nombre d'actions qui
ont eu vraiment des retombées très
positives pour le territoire
mais maintenant faut aller faut aller
plus loin faut se coordonner davantage
l'avenir passera donc par une action
collective afin de répondre aux besoins
du territoire et pour cela chaque forces
en présence doit adapter ses objectifs
au service des familles réunionnaises
temps se doit aujourd'hui d'adapter nos
politiques parce que je les besoins des
familles évolue change est un des
objectifs majeurs de ce schéma et de
toutes les politiques publiques c'est de
répondre au mieux aux besoins des
familles en difficulté
si on ne s'adapte pas ça voudrait dire
que les familles auront des difficultés
auront besoin de présenter des projets
on sera pas au rendez vous avec 40 % des
familles en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
102 mille bénéficiaires du rsa ajoutez à
cela la crise sanitaire les enjeux
déficience sont prioritaires si on
oublie le moindre acteurs on aura des
trous dans la raquette et je pense que
l'ambition d'une feuille de route comme
l'a précisé monsieur le président du
département à l'instant en signant ce
que on y voit clair je pense que les
temps sont à la 1re serrer les rangs et
puis effectivement être cohérent dans
nos actions lors de ce colloque 17
acteurs ont signé avec le département
cet axe stratégique
une manière d'articuler des politiques
publiques tous les dispositifs existants
et le plan national de lutte contre la
pauvreté
[Musique]